I think these brothers also need to
realize that the future of this Omar is
in these children we're waiting for you
know a child to come and help us out
don't kill them execute that dream don't
don't kill these kids don't put them
down we need kids out there who loved at
the this Dean will love this this
religion who love the Quran who are
proud of and and and they come out there
and they say were Muslims and and we
need that Tavia regarding children and
it's something were after this program
it was specifically having to do with
teachers using verbal sending verbal
messages to kids that didn't empower
them but it kind of demoralized them
their confidence their self-esteem and
then it opened up a conversation with
people also coming out and talking about
how they also they left Islam at one
point because they remembered a
particular teacher hitting them or using
some language with them and then they
hung a lot they came back and then even
some Imams that I spoke to they also
were talking about how this is kind of
like a a a secret I an open secret that
this is something that needs to be
talked about it's something that people
have inherited from their country
they're they're they're doing these same
methods and I've even heard someone
mentioned a certain person was telling
me just one justification I see what
your one is it's really crazy that you
know when the prophet saw something he
got the revelation that came to him he
was squeezed I don't know if you ever
heard this one so people who do this
type of method they'll say well the
Prophet SAW some you know we're teaching
Quran so the prophet saw him before he
got caught he was squeezed very tight
inflicted with some pain so we have to
inflict that was one some people also
talk about the hadith where the prophet
saw some said your
guide your children to pray at 7:00 and
then discipline them by the by the time
they're eight uh no ten I'm sorry so
they'll use some of these these hadith
so I wanted to continue on from there
some of yours on what I've just said and
what do you have to say about first of
all the you know I was amazing because I
I'm presenting right now the seal of the
prophets of awesome it's available
online as well
it's called know your messenger and I
happen to be just presenting that scene
of the squeezing and the wisdom behind
it you know we got this guy the crazy
guy Salman Rushdie I think he came up
with that thing called Satanic Verses
he's basically saying that these are
thoughts personal thoughts so the
squeezing years to show you that you
have two entities two individuals
interacting with one another Jibril
alehissalaam and the prophet sallallaahu
so it's not internal you know thoughts
just to expel that welcome to the
subject of you know command them to pray
at the age of seven and then at the age
of ten go ahead and and and and punish
them if they do not do what will come to
this for a minute but let me begin by
the issue that can you use this or
punish discipline same thing yes
discipline
yeah discipline the issue that we have a
deal with this subject is it has nothing
to do with that
actually these are weak evidence that
are taken completely out of context to
justify something that is wrong
something that is to be corrected it has
to be corrected because this is wrong
this is absolutely wrong what's wrong
demoralizing calling student names and
and and I have to admit I used to be a
teacher at one stage of my life I used
to do this and I realized that that this
is wrong you see the problem with a lot
of these teach give some examples of
nights of hurt yeah the problem with
these teachers they came from overseas
and older acids is the memorization of
the Quran but they have not gone through
any curriculum psychology of a child a
curriculum of how to teach the manners
and the etiquettes of teaching and they
even do not use the proper evidence to
teach them if you're gonna if you're
gonna say that you're completely a
religious guy you don't want to go into
that conventional kind of you know
education you know to become a teacher
in America you have to go through you
have it you have to have a teaching
degree right you see they don't only
teach you what to teach they teach you
the psychology then the interaction of
the child pedagogy on the mat we'll
don't go through this so and now he goes
after one or two evidence and taking
them out of context to justify what he's
doing wrong or to justify what I'm doing
wrong
maybe meanwhile you have tons of
evidence that teaches you that you need
to be soft you need to be kind to the
children the Prophet SAW solemn and has
spent ten years with him he didn't do
that with him one time he told him to do
something he did not do it he he looked
at him and he smiled and he left he
understand for you have multiple
evidence a lot of them that show you
that you have to be soft you have to be
kind
I think the point here is we are trying
to teach American children and I'm sorry
I'm making this exclusive to Americans
but let's say European children in
Europe or in America using techniques
that were brought up with back in then
and in the Middle East in a different
time in a different place so we live in
a different time in a different place
different environment huh and we want to
use techniques and and
and that that were implemented in a
different time in a different place
that's exactly what the problem is and
all what were after is bringing out some
weak taken out of context evidence in
order to justify this this is wrong
Eddie you need to understand this the
teacher can be a great impact on a child
because he contributes to the upbringing
of the child like the parents but at the
same time he can be a devastating impact
on that child and you mentioned I know
certain people who left Islam because of
the teachers because of something that
they saw in their teachers and I know
some people who love Islam because of
the teachers so we need to reconsider
and I call upon the brothers and the
sisters who came from overseas
don't don't submit to that reality
because it's wrong it's wrong please for
the sake of Allah we love you you know
we love you and we appreciate you
because you memorize the Quran and
you're helping the AMA revive this
tradition but you need to understand
that there are there is a lot that you
do not know about Tapia
there is a lot that you do not know
about teachings and you need to consider
maybe if you're not willing to take a
class is to listen to the advice a rose
also allah salem advise us when we teach
people when we try to convey the message
conveyed with kindness softness you
should not put down the person you
should not do that you should actually
encourage them to do that
yes punishment or you would rather use
the word discipline I am okay with that
too discipline in Islam is an element
there is no question about Allah created
Jannah and nor heaven and hell no
furnace but once it comes you see
is an everlasting eternal you know
punishment or eternal reward this is
after you conclude your mission but
we're talking about children who are
going through the age of Turbie you know
what erbia is that you try to modify
change their pattern of behavior
now what works if calling them names
bullying them as a teach bling bullying
them I'm sorry the word is well put them
down demoralize them make them resent it
will you do it no shouldn't shouldn't do
it you should do what helps them to
change to be better people
and I tell you what the American kids
the lollipop the Gen approach works a
lot and that's you know then I think
these brothers also need to realize that
the future of this Omaha is in these
children we're waiting for you know a
child to come and help us out don't kill
them execute that dream don't don't kill
these kids don't put them down we need
kids out there who love that the this
Dean all of this this religion who loved
the Quran who are proud of and and they
come out there and they say we're
Muslims and and we need that you know
we're having issues now Eddie with with
our children they are leaving Islam some
of them some of them they shy away from
even saying that they are Muslims did
they change their names to more one so
this is just another excuse another door
that opens that you're helping anything
love it yeah you see that the prophesy
was the greatest teacher of the apostle
of course no one can attain his but at
least we need to try
he made his companions love the cools
love the cause yeah you as a teacher you
make them love the Quran yeah you make
them love memorizing the Quran you make
them enjoy the experience it will make a
difference in their lives
but don't tell me that you're trying to
you see it snowing it's known if
somebody does something you want from
them I would feel the moment that fear
is lifted they're not gonna do it
yeah yes maybe he doesn't want to be
called the name maybe he doesn't want to
be pushed around all right
that's why he's gonna go up let me
memorize because I do want to hear this
teacher man I'm tired of this teacher
but the moment that he doesn't feel you
know more it's over he's not gonna do it
but imagine doing it out of love
man I love the ha it's teacher you know
when when when I memorize and even if I
make a mistake he explains it to me and
it makes a difference it it's a whole
different thing yeah yeah you were I
would I want to say something you're
gonna go back I wouldn't say something
yes
and Allah is my witness I used to do
these wrong things and I learned the
hard way and that is why I'm calling
upon my brothers who are in this field
who have not you know I'm telling you
reconsider reconsider you know or learn
you know we're human we make mistakes
that's really praiseworthy when someone
can admit to a mistake and come out and
what wait I didn't know I didn't know
better
yeah you know when you do something out
of not knowing yeah even for you
yeah it's believing in Allah you're
actually giving an execute because of
not knowing yeah yeah you were gonna go
back to the hadith about prayer what
were you gonna say about that
yeah about 7:00 and guide them to prayer
at 7:00 and then discipline them by 10
well were you gonna comment on that yeah
well you see that it's discipline yeah
it's busy what's the contest because you
know what that's someone you know what
the context I heard I heard someone you
know what the context is please tell me
that he knows that you have that sight
but you don't exercise it
you know that you have that authority
you know that you can punish it's like
ideally they say he sees the stick
hanging on the wall but you never bring
it down hmm
is that a Fanta Khedive about to stick
well yeah there is a Hassan yeah but
shed is you don't bring it down but he
knows yeah and that takes teachings you
know that listen you know don't mess
around with me yeah but you could convey
this still that harshness the toughness
in your character you could convey it in
a way that is decent without humiliating
demoralizing the person but at the same
time if he is doing his job if he's
struggling if he's driving you need to
understand also the the state of mind of
your student if he is trying you know if
he's not doing it then you can show a
little bit of harshness that's what is
meant by it yeah when you look at I was
taking I'm taking a class on Islamic on
on University and pedagogy education and
kids and whatnot education in general
and when you dwell into this it is
profound how many how many different
psychologists avenues there are you know
any studies and human behaviors but
someone says look all I need is Crown
and Sunnah even Quran and Sunnah doesn't
back you doesn't back this up that's the
point I'm trying to make even if you've
been at will and Quran and Sunnah I can
sit out here and quote to you how
rasulullah saaw Salim treated imagine
imagine this imagine this Rasul Allah
Allah Allah Allah is sitting in the
middle of his campaign I'll give you
just one one pattern one example I'm
sorry one example with his company
Holly from standing mmm I've met a
little young male behavior of the Allah
on a young man approaches the Prophet
the teacher guess what he's asking I
want to commit adultery and you're going
to give me a permission right here
that's a moment that you can cease to
beat this guy up to death
and that's actually some of the
companions attempted to do that man
Takei but that can be a teaching moment
yeah
Oh leave him alone good new Norman the
guy urinated in the moisture yeah that's
another one yeah you know odd new but
this is this is a one that odd new come
close look at this teaching moments here
teaching moments I thought my hair lumic
would you like someone to do this to
your mother
they are no oma see what unless people
wouldn't like this - I thought actually
resources Ellen kept me at of the
harelip netic if you have a daughter I
thought oh if you have a sister if you
have a hand if you have material matters
not and he kept actually there is no boy
into free meeting this again would you
imagine someone coming to you and then
doing this yeah
so our Dean doesn't close the door to
get that that knowledge where could we
use the hadith where the promise of some
had said that knowledge is a lost
treasure of the believer wherever he can
grab it so in these areas now the
teacher is being taught how to teach
that's an art and of its I teach I mean
I teach been teaching martial arts for
you know over it almost 20 years now and
it I can understand you know we also
have children there if we would use any
of these methods we'd be out of business
you follow me and there's art in
teaching it's an art you know I mean
especially with children are and the
adults are different but now going
there's nothing where you're putting
yourself back you're actually moving
forward when you take a class specific
class three weeks month two months no
you're only going to grow so listen and
shouldn't we be people if we're people
of Quran and Sunnah
shouldn't we be ready for change at any
time to adjust our behavior to do to to
thing to the right thing always whatever
we're right Rock we're ready to modify
to change according to karana see so if
we've been doing some for 20 years 30
years it's not right I have to tell you
the truth comes to us that it is the
Western world excelled in this
they created you know rules rulebook
yeah for a teacher you can do do do not
do and if you actually trace these are
Islamic so each one of those I can give
you evidence from the Quran and this one
not incident that happened in it so why
not why not adopt it why not
Shaitaan one time told Abu Hurairah
something imagined Shaitaan told uh
before I was something but the story
about ayatul kursi before you go to
sleep yes some of the people may not be
aware of it but went to the prophet
Solomon he said he said this to me and
he said he spoke the truth this one is
good take it from him take it from him
cause it's the truth siddhappa
kauahikaua even though he's not telling
the truth in other areas but this one
because of the truth take the truth take
the truth even from you know you
understand I think my point is yeah so
the truth is there were people of karna
soon I will take it yeah and we grow
from it we learn from it we become
better teachers when I come yeah
and the last thing is I mean because a
people a person T people according to
their position they're held at certain
levels right so policeman has a
responsibility teacher and math has a
certain respondent now teach of Quran
I mean this is our teacher of Islam
that's a whole we look at doctors have
certain they take the Hippocratic oath
do no harm you know the doctor but now
the Quran teacher the Islamic teacher
this is at a whole nother level have a
golden opportunity yeah to impact this
boy's life this girl's life yeah
I tell you golden opportunity to have a
place in their lives you can be a king
without a crown in their lives they can
respect you love you even when your name
is mentioned after your death they will
they will invoke the mercy of Allah Banu
yeah and you can be a disgraced or if
your means for them believe that he you
can be you know this race
Ya Allah protect us from that yeah
choose the right thing yes sure Thank
You Shea we covered a lot gradually look
of Chicago and visit with you idiot
you're getting old man I'm dying it I
should do something about it
thank you six Salaam alaikum
thank you guys for tuning in subscribe
if you haven't already and we're here
every week here on the D show a new and
exciting episode we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you Allah make